although mad max fury road got rave
reviews
rosie huntington whiteley didn't use her
part as a springboard to advance her
acting career
in fact you might not have seen rosie in
a hot minute here's why
mad max fury road was universally
praised and rosie huntington whiteley's
performance was well received
however her big screen debut in
transformers dark of the moon
was panned by critics in the third
installment of the transformers
franchise
huntington whiteley replaced megan fox
as shia labeouf's love interest
the reviews were so scathing it's no
wonder she didn't appear in another film
for four years
a review from total film remarked rosie
huntington whiteley was sucking the life
out of every scene she appeared in
every entertainer knows that they can't
please everyone and the transformers
franchise was never a hit with critics
no matter who was part of the human cast
however huntington whiteley said she did
her best to pay attention and learn from
the role
shortly after the release of mad max
fury road rosie huntington whiteley
and her boyfriend jason statham went
public with the exciting news that
they'd gotten engaged
huntington whiteley showed off her
sparkly new rock at the golden globes in
january 2016.
the couple has been together since 2010
and huntington whiteley says that
statham has been much more understanding
of her ambitious career goals than some
of her previous boyfriends
are you threatened by him
[Laughter]
huntington whiteley and statham are both
extremely passionate about their work
and this connection only makes their
relationship stronger as the model and
actress told elle australia
when you're a career driven person it
works best when your partner is equally
as excited for you and supportive
and that's what jason is he's my biggest
cheerleader and i'm his
although they're both quite busy with
their respective careers they like to
have plenty of family time outside of
the spotlight and huntington whiteley
makes it a point to keep their
relationship fairly private
they both make an effort to make the
most of their time off together
which means not taking on every project
that comes their way
rosie huntington whiteley wears many
professional hats and by putting acting
on the back burner she was able to focus
on some of her other passions
like fashion design she had already
worked on a lingerie line for british
brand marx and spencer which turned out
to be a massive success
so it's easy to see why the label page
chose to partner with her for a
collaborative collection
this was a huge undertaking but
huntington whiteley was happy to take on
the challenge
as she told l i've always wanted to be a
designer ever since i can remember
it's brilliant to come to work and bring
something else to the table besides my
modeling
it's great when people want to listen to
you and want you to be a part of
something bigger than just being the
face of a brand
the first collection was launched in
february 2017
and a second was launched in the fall of
2017. it's clear that this is an area
where huntington whiteley really excels
and feels comfortable expressing herself
creatively
with all the time she spent acting
modeling and working on her other
business ventures
it's hard to imagine how rosie
huntington whiteley could possibly fit
anything more into her busy life
eventually juggling all of these
commitments was bound to become too much
and as a result certain projects
inevitably fell by the wayside
shortly before being cast in mad max
fury road huntington whiteley had been
pushing for the presenter spot on the
long-running reality tv series
project runway all-stars after getting
confirmation that she'd landed the job
she abruptly backpedaled
unfortunately for the show this all went
down mere weeks before filming was
slated to begin
when she was offered the part in mad max
fury road she decided that her role in
the film was more important
which unexpectedly left the cast and
crew of project runway all-stars
in search of a different host it isn't
uncommon for scheduling conflicts to
happen in hollywood
but it still probably didn't do her any
favors with the people behind the scenes
at project runway all-stars and she may
have realized that choosing hollywood
over the fashion industry
might not be such a smart career move
trying to do it all would just mean
spreading herself too thin
in june 2017 rosie huntington whiteley
and jason statham welcomed their son
jack
like pretty much any doting mom
huntington whiteley never misses a
chance to gush about how much she loves
him
although she did take several months off
to stay home with jack and adjust to
being a new mom
she says that since she came back to
work she and statham now try to split
their parenting
responsibilities equally with statham's
time on film sets it would be difficult
for both of them to balance time with
jack if huntington whiteley was acting
too
now their schedule works out perfectly
statham is in charge of jack in the
morning while huntington whiteley takes
care of the nighttime routine and puts
him to bed
he is very happy to get up at 5am in the
morning
and like do daddy duties the couple is
adamant that their son should be raised
with plenty of involvement from both
parents
as the model told harper's bazaar i
think it's so much about raising boys
and girls the same
that's how i was brought up it's how the
people i love were brought up
and they are the values i hope to
instill in my loved ones
ask any parent how their life has
changed after they've had a kid
and many will probably tell you that
they're not too keen on staying late at
the office anymore
as they would rather get home early and
have plenty of time with their family
instead
as it turns out even celebrities
struggle to strike that balance
rosie huntington whiteley has been very
forthcoming about the fact that she now
considers her son
jack's needs before she agrees to take
any potential new job
she told harper's bazaar the first thing
in your mind before accepting a job is
what's right for my family the new thing
is getting used to having a lot of
responsibilities in my personal life and
career
for every woman it's a juggle we've been
so like focused on
our work for so long and then jack came
along
in the early days of her career rosie
huntington whiteley
couldn't afford to be picky with her
projects and just like any new model
she had to be open-minded about the jobs
that came her way but now
she's certainly not scrounging for work
as one of the most in-demand models in
the industry
she can be as choosy as she wants to be
and she calls the shots
it seems that 30 was the magic turning
point for huntington whiteley
after spending nearly 15 years in the
industry she felt like she had finally
gained a solid grasp
on the kinds of jobs that she did or
didn't want to take on as she told
harper's bazaar uk
i've settled into my life i know myself
and what makes me happy
rosie huntington whiteley started her
lifestyle brand rose inc
while taking her hiatus from modeling to
stay home with son jack
huntington whiteley says that while
acting or modeling other people are
typically in control of the decisions in
final product
but she wanted to pursue a project where
she would have the final say
after years of taking direction from
others she was ready to make a statement
and kick off a whole new phase in her
career she told nedoporte
i just never felt comfortable sitting
back and waiting for other people to
make decisions for me
i've always wanted to be in control of
where my life is going
right now the site features interviews
with models and beauty industry
moguls updates on innovative new
products and makeup tutorials
it's clear that this is huntington
whiteley's passion and it's a space
where she gets to share all of her
interest in beauty know-how with her
friends
[Music]
as for why she didn't try to establish
herself as an actress
after the success of mad max fury road
rosie huntington whiteley is a model
first and foremost
as of 2018 huntington whiteley was
ranked 6th on the forbes official
rankings of the highest earning models
in the world
and those rankings were released while
she was on her maternity break
at this point she has the freedom to
fully lean into the talents that have
taken her to the top of the ladder and
she knows that she has always had a
certain natural gift for modeling and
fashion design
there's a time for trying new things and
there's a time for embracing your innate
talents and just running with them
and that seems to be where huntington
whiteley is at right now
it's really about you know enhancing the
things that you love about yourself and
playing on those things
at the beginning of her modeling career
rosie huntington whiteley said she was
simply expected to sit in front of the
camera and look pretty
and she was frustrated with the
expectation that models should stay
silent
she says that over the past few years
she's gotten sick of that feeling and if
she can't give her
input and take part in the artistic
process she's just not interested
huntington whiteley told nedaporte if
shoots aren't a collaborative process
then i'm not really interested
because i don't want to feel like i did
for the first 10 years of my career
which is that i was just having stuff
done to me and as a newcomer to
hollywood
huntington whiteley probably didn't have
much sway when it came to how she played
her roles
perhaps she missed feeling confident in
having a certain level of authority
while having a director in charge of her
every move
rosie huntington whiteley's dream was
always to become a model
and she made that dream come true at a
young age but becoming an actress was
never one of her goals
those roles happened to fall into her
lap and while she was grateful for the
chance to be part of two franchises that
she was a fan of
acting wasn't part of her long-term
career plan huntington whiteley told the
daily telegraph
they were just incredible opportunities
that i've grasped i think you'll agree
when you get to be in a film like mad
max or transformers you'd be crazy to
say no and turn that down
huntington whiteley has always seen
herself as a model before anything else
she has the incredible career that she
has always envisioned and while she's
glad that she gave acting a shot
it just wasn't for her after spending
years in hollywood
rosie huntington whiteley and her family
decided to pack up and move to london in
the uk
on instagram huntington whiteley
frequently shares photos from her
spacious new home
and she occasionally posts shots from
around the city since huntington
whiteley was born and raised in england
it's safe to say that she wanted to be
closer to her family
and perhaps she was just feeling a
little homesick after living so far from
her loved ones while there are plenty of
opportunities for actors in london
it's unlikely that huntington whiteley
would want to relocate there if she
intended to return to acting
of course actors don't necessarily need
to be based in los angeles in order to
land roles
but it certainly does help maybe she'll
decide to come back to california one
day but for now
it looks like huntington whiteley and
her family will be staying on the other
side of the pond
huntington whiteley wanted to go beyond
running her own beauty site
she's also passionate about high quality
cosmetics
and she's had the opportunity to
collaborate with several top beauty
brands to create new products
in 2020 huntington whiteley became the
first celebrity ambassador for hourglass
cosmetics and she launched a new line of
concealers and lipsticks with the brand
in january 2021 huntington whiteley
worked with another beauty brand
la bouche rouge to release two new
shades of lipstick
she announced that a portion of the
proceeds from this particular collection
will go to the non-profit organization
uviv international
which provides communities with clean
drinking water huntington whiteley has
spoken of her admiration for the beauty
brand on numerous occasions and told the
zoe report
i first came across labour's rules soon
after it launched in 2017
and instantly fell in love with the
sustainability mission the clean
formulations
and how the lipstick cases felt like a
keepsake while huntington whiteley may
not be acting right now
she's certainly busy enough with other
projects
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one